il est coutume de parler de deux europes
en différenciant la vieille europe des
pays fondateurs à l'ouest de la nouvelle
europe des entrants plus récents à l'est
mais aujourd'hui on pourrait également
faire la différence entre pays du sud et
pays du nord au sud tous les pays ont
une dette énorme
en 2010 8 181 % du pib en grèce 132 % en
italie le 100 % pour la france
oui on met la france dans les pays du
sud alors qu'au nord mise à part la
belgique
d autres ont une dette en trombe 8,4
pour cent pour l'estonie et 73 5% pour
l'autriche
les déficits publics sont aussi bien
plus important pour les pays du sud
dépassant la plupart du temps les 2% a
contrario du nord où on trouve même des
excédents budgétaires comme en allemagne
ou aux pays bas les pays du nord sont en
fait plus libres économiquement et la
rigueur budgétaire y est plus élevé dans
l'index of economic freedom qui classe
les pays selon leur liberté économique
irlandais 6e le danemark 14 yens la
suède 19e
quand l'espagne et 57e la france 71e ou
l'adresse 106e de quoi rabattre en tout
cas les cartes des pays forts de
l'europe entre le breakbeat et
l'économie vacillante de la france on
est loin du trio
faure france royaume uni allemagne cette
fracture nord sud pourrait déboucher sur
une europe du nord où les pays font du
commerce entrevoir peut-être sur une
nouvelle zone monétaire
le projet a déjà été évoqué et en face
une europe du sud à la ramasse
économiquement